les occasions pour l'exécutif de
s'autocongratuler sont rares en ce
moment alors quand le gouvernement a vu
paraître cette étude du hem haïti il a
saisi l'opportunité
la france quatrième pays le plus vert du
monde découvre ton dans le rapport
publié par les chercheurs
très vite membres du gouvernement et de
la majorité s'empresse de crier cocorico
et en profite pour vanter leur propre
politique
ce classement c'est un classement qui
rend hommage à tous les efforts qui ont
été faits en particulier dans cette
mandature c'est la volonté de mettre la
transition écologique au coeur de notre
action dans la foulée cet enthousiasme
va être douchés par des scientifiques
qui se penchent sur la méthodologie
utilisée par les chercheurs du hem haïti
il apparaît ainsi qu'une large partie
40% de la note est en fait attribué sur
des promesses politiques comme on peut
d'ailleurs le lire dans l'introduction
de l'étude
le green futur index est un classement
de 66 pays basé sur leurs progrès et
leur engagement à bâtir un avenir sobre
en carbone des engagements dont on n'a
aucune certitude qu'ils seront tenus
mais qui suffisent donc à attribuer des
bons et des mauvais points
d'ailleurs le gouvernement français a
déjà été épinglée dans le cadre de la
sphère du siècle pour son inaction
climatique
l'état français ayant été condamnées
justement pour ne pas avoir respecté ses
engagements en matière de réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
même dans ce classement du hem haïti les
indicateurs factuelles sont moins
flatteurs pour l'hexagone la france
13e pour les émissions de carbone 57e
selon les critères d'une société verte
et même 62e en ce qui concerne la
transition énergétique de plus pour ce
qui est par exemple des émissions de
carbone
le classement ne prend en compte que la
production et non la consommation
les importations d'hydrocarbures
notamment ne sont donc pas prises en
compte pour établir ce palmarès
toutes ces précisions viennent nuancer
la bonne place occupée par la france
dans ce classement des pays les plus
vert du monde
pour autant tout n'est pas à jeter dans
la politique française de lutte contre
le dérèglement climatique
la france est par exemple salué pour ses
investissements dans l'hydrogène
et pour ce chercheur cité par le
huffington post
ce classement du hem haïti revêt surtout
une importance d'ordre symbolique
les militants de l'environnement oublie
parfois que les politiques ont besoin
d'encouragements ce genre de classement
ne doit pas être utilisé pour se dire
qu'on est bon mais pour qu'on regarde là
où les autres ont réussi du côté du
gouvernement on ne s'intéresse que très
peu à ces remises en cause de la
méthodologie de l'étude on préfère se
focaliser sur le classement final
une classification très largement relayé
sur les réseaux sociaux par des membres
de la majorité certains en profitant
pour glisser quelques tac à leurs
opposants
mais la politique environnementale de
l'exécutif reste contestée car elle ne
permettrait pas de respecter les
engagements de l'accord de paris sur le
climat selon le collectif la sphère du
siècle la france aurait dépassé le 17
mars dernier le seuil annuel nécessaire
pour atteindre la neutralité carbone
selon les estimations de ce collectif de
militants écologistes
à ce rythme les objectifs fixé pour
l'horizon 2050 ne seront atteints qu'en
2000 84